three eunuchs on the panel right now
Jacob Alfie Khan let's do you guys have
a support group how does it work you
know we have an arts arts and crafts
group so we've made various ornaments
with our you know we've got earrings and
one of us have supplied a couple of
doorstops that's all I'm saying
well Alfie I got to ask you because
you've actually decided to go with it
you when you sign an autograph you do it
in a special way that's sort of a
tribute to what many people know about
your character yeah I mean people seem
to really like it they asked me to sort
of draw a severed penis on my autograph
as your autograph no eyes my autograph -
what is that when you're like writing a
cheque you write your name and then
there's a chopped off dick at the end
my player this no one's gonna Forge that
you know my hand just started to get
tired
you